okay so byronique
um when's the last time you were in a
relationship
I say like 2020 was my last situation
[__]
okay by the way you say you like white
dudes like am I your type or what
I gotta I gotta feel you out I gotta get
your Vibe we gotta hang out a little bit
soccer you feel me but look wise yeah
you got the pretty little blue eyes Paul
Walker going on
[Applause]
here
should the rest of the sleeve
yeah this is gonna be a a date
the dating show finally got y'all a day
let's go let's go okay cool
all right we'll uh talk after the show
okay all right
um you're single
rip
um
how long have you been single
uh like
like two almost three years okay
um and we were actually
wait single two yeah and you're waiting
until marriage yes to
you know yeah do the deed for religious
reasons or uh let's get the mic towards
you please yeah honestly let's get it to
the edge okay yeah for religious reasons
and are you Christian Catholic I'm
Catholic okay
okay uh married
relationship and then Pearl is in the
bathroom Okay
um
got a question
but you're not really single though
right there's some dude come on there's
some dude in the picture there's so many
like there's so many I'm just kidding
I'm kind of kidding
but I I mean yeah I am single like fully
wait can you I'm sorry to keep doing
this get the mic that way but there we
go
um I look better like this you said
there's so many dudes how many guys are
you talking to right now no I'm I was
joking I was joking
I honestly I'd honestly drop all of them
for somebody in this room
who
no no no I'm never mind are you you're
you're bi who would you who
Kiki
this one oh Kiki which I have known each
other forever this is my sister
what Kiki and I have known each other
for Forever This is my you said someone
in this room yeah I'm gonna let it
remain a mystery you can figure it out
who play eeny meeny miny moe
is she a roommate
no but I I do I have already filmed
content with every single girl that is a
roommate of mine
is it is it blessing
he's got a girlfriend dude no I'm not I
would never hit on a guy with a
girlfriend that's where I draw a line I
don't do that that's disrespectful stop
the cow
that ass if they tell me they have a
girlfriend I'm they're off they're
they're not no that's not me
oh
okay
is it
is it Nick
I think that that's a yes wait is it is
it I think I think I don't know I think
I need some more yeah throw your friend
under the bus we promised we wouldn't
say anything together we can't do that
we'll start having house fights again oh
my God more than usual okay is it a girl
or is the guy
that's no fun if I tell you that then it
limits it because there's so many women
in here
so it's a chick no oh wait
is it Nick this is so red his face is so
red
it's his first W but my name's l
ol he's not riding home with us
I don't care
um wait but how many guys are you dating
right now I'm not I'm not like what's
the last time you hooked up with a dude
yeah I watched it so badly but I'm so
bad at saying no bro
okay
the last time I hooked up really dude
was like maybe like two days ago yeah
maybe two days ago yeah something like
28 hours yeah okay
um yeah
but like I said drop them all for Nick
foreign
but this guy you recently hooked up with
are you going to continue seeing him or
is it was it a one-time thing
I don't even want to talk about it
these girls I don't even want to talk
about it they're just gonna [__] I
don't even want to talk about it but I
really can't wait is it just four of you
in the house or is there no there's
eight of us there's eight of us yes oh
there's nine there's nine of us oh yeah
there's nine of us yeah
you all mean eight all different kinds
of ways yeah do you each have your own
bedroom or do you share yes this is like
a mansion or something yes in La where
is it
Sherman Oaks why would we say that
exposed
I just narrowed it down way too much
there's too many hot females in that
house for us to say what sometimes I
forget I'm talking to a lot of people
yeah how do you guys live with that many
women
we used to no honestly okay it's it's
been better we've almost swung it it's a
merry-go-round of who's arguing with you
yeah even better who argues the most
with each other out of the foreign
but we're like sisters yeah me we make
up quicker than we argue you know what I
mean like we're we're we've been on a
good streak though yeah this is so four
days this is the longest we've gone
without arguing about anything to be
honest which is crazy stuff but actually
the stupid is like not even significant
the last time we really got into an
argument was about my baby daddy yeah
yeah because it was my friend yeah
hook up with him too no
but he didn't eat me out
but that's as much as I let him go
that's a hookup I love how he's watching
this he is watching right now does that
not count as a hookup I mean it wasn't
like he could have gotten me pregnant
too so I consider that a win
that was a one-time drunk thing for them
and then yeah I'm being very good
friends after that so yeah and it was
completely platonic after that
wow okay
how do you go you straight you straight
you strive for me to be so brutally
honest and I'll do it I'll put myself
I'm not afraid I appreciate it like I
own my own [__] that's why people did
you have something no I just can't
imagine like going from that to being
like platonic friends like I think you
can yeah no 100 when you don't when you
don't have like that sexual connection
with someone it just kind of it honestly
like ruled it out for both of us and it
just made us more of just like okay
you're the homies I do not believe that
minimum I've been that close proximity
friends if you're not attracted to each
other so do you think I have a question
do you think disrespectful if you are
dating someone new and you have someone
around that you've hooked up with before
yes
I think it did yeah I think it one
depends on the comfortability of you and
in your relationship if it's something
new then like if that's a boundary for
the other person then that's supposed to
be something that's communicated and
respected both ways but if if you were
if you were like you can't go out to a
club and then get mad at your girlfriend
or your boyfriend or whatever situation
you're in if there's somebody that
they're that they've hooked up with or
been attached to in the past there
because that's not means like
choosing to keep someone in your life
hanging out with them and stuff like
that you've hooked up with in the past
even though you're in a committed
relationship yeah I don't know I think
that's 100 yeah I think it's just I
think it's disrespectful to the partner
if it's if that's like something that's
discussed between the two of you guys
that's I know it really is so
circumstantial that it's hard
yeah that's that's huge relationship I
just kind of think of things from like a
guy's point of view so I'm thinking if
I'm a guy and I'm like looking to date a
girl like why would I want to date a
girl that has a bunch of dudes around
that have like ate her out or after well
I don't isn't that isn't that kind of a
red flag no 110 if that's
like I said I'm single for a [__]
reason
like and but sometimes like you know
people stay friends with their ex you
know their ex sometimes they have like a
x like marriage
like you know sometimes a friendship
remains like I mean I think it really
depends like on the nature of the
relationship like is there really a
friendship after though I think I always
say codependency or is it yeah what is
it depend on the situation because one
of my exes we are like not attracted to
each other anymore at all on any level
whatsoever but I love this person so
much as the person that he is and like
we are just very good friends like I've
met his current girlfriend and like
she's very aware of the situation and
like I respect their relationship 100 I
feel like it's very I don't believe me
yeah but if you had a boyfriend who said
the same thing about one of his friends
would you feel comfortable with him
hanging out with her yeah okay okay
maybe I think it does depend on the
situation because men don't see that
they I I don't think that that's I don't
think that's a thing for men I think
it's on or off that's that's the only
way they view it so they're just waiting
they're just waiting but it's just like
that I think it's just like that with
women too like it's like an on and off
switch I think for me personally if I'm
in like a friendship with a guy and I've
hooked up with them before it like Al
said it rules it cancels out that kind
of like I feel like every guy and girl
friendship has some kind of level of
sexual attention yeah that's yeah I
agree with you so I think once that is
like rules and it's like okay yeah I do
I do have some guy anymore
at all I think you can genuinely have a
good friendship
I'm not saying that that's the only way
to have a good friendship but I think
that that is like you can still be
friends with somebody that you've slept
with before
okay let me get a couple of the chats uh
let's get caught up here Akira I think
for the five gifted everyone who's
watching on Twitch by the way
um unfortunately we can't shout anybody
out because our uh what's that can
somebody fix that peeping hello just
unplug the monitor I guess just from the
back
that should hopefully fix it all right
guys as usual uh yeah shout out to
everyone on Twitch go to twitch.tv slash
whatever drop us a prime sub drop us a
follow if you have one uh twitch.tv
whatever mods if you could spam in the
chat yeah sorry guys it's a little hard
to run the show because our monitor's
gone it's uh scuffed so okay we have a
chat here from
tote toe Lu
alimi thank you all right this one's
okay last show a few panelists when
asked well I think it was one panelist
but when asked what advice they'd give
to women who are physically abused in
relationships said the the partner
should stay in the relationship and
endure curious your takes Brian and
Pearl and the rest of the panel too
okay yeah this is like went crazy viral
on Twitter and a couple other places
yeah
first off the CL the short clip that Mel
posted uh I I don't know if she edited
it or if it was somebody else uh was
like cut it was pretty heavily cut up
um MLD was saying that you should endure
I'm not even sure if he said like I
think he was talking about in general
but like because she threw in well what
should you do in divorce and then she
threw in this other stuff about abuse I
mean Point Blank period Mike my take is
if you're being abused whether
emotionally physically whatever it may
be but your question is physically
abused like
get out like and the relationship get
divorced like that don't stay
um however they decided to like crop in
like Chase and then they cropped in Mary
and then John and then they put I didn't
even say anything during that entire
segment and they put me in the segment
and then like people are thinking every
single one of us like they showed our
face in the segment that we co-signed on
his endure statement which is not true
if you're an abusive relationship like
marriage relationship whatever uh that's
pretty justifiable extremely justifiable
reason to leave and get out go ahead
Pearl
full clip of
clip of fries I didn't really take it
but that's what he meant but when they
cut it up like that it just seemed like
he said something it didn't say but
that's what a lot of these like
reactions and I'll say this as a content
creator like a lot of the reaction
channels will take Clips to like put you
out of context and like say things that
you didn't say and kind of like it's
really dishonest honestly and and Mel
the Destiny's uh wife it was her clip
that she made which I think is pretty
disingenuous because if you watch the
whole thing I think MLD got a little
like he was [__] seven white clothes
deep too look if he I'm not I'm not
going to co-sign what he said static
disavow but like it sounded like to me
like they were asking about divorce in
general and he was saying endure endure
and then like somewhere through that he
she brings up uh physical abuse and so
well and so I kind of look at this
question a little differently
because my question is like what is the
abusive situation and I need specifics
and like the reason I need specifics is
women cry abuse for everything and we've
actually lost the meaning of abuse
like if you go to and and I know this
because I I'm doing a divorce
documentary and so I'm actually
interviewing men that are in the process
of getting like absolutely wrecked by
divorce and a lot of them have had false
allegations put out against them and a
lot of those um basically what the
feminists do is they expand the
definition of abuse to include things
like coercive control Financial abuse
and even physical abuse a lot of times
like girls don't talk about how they hit
first and most abusive situations are
mutually abusive meaning they're both
hitting each other and so a lot of times
what girls will do is they'll say oh I'm
being abused but they don't talk about
how she hit him first like I had a girl
on the show say I was physically abused
and I used to just believe women like I
genuinely I would always just be like oh
I'm so sorry but then you start asking
questions and it it's it baffles me how
women like
turn the situation of them like being
abused when they aren't like this one
girl she came on my show she said I was
physically abused I said okay tell me
the situation what exactly happened he
she refused to leave his house
she she refused she like so she's trust
passing on his property saying I'm not
going to leave and he pushes her out of
the house is that abuse or another thing
that girls do is they'll they'll Edge a
guy on like I saw a clip of a dude of a
girl
um
basically making fun of a guy for having
a dead son and he hit her who abused who
and that's like the other side of this
that we don't talk about is that a lot
of times like the feminists or whatever
will try to get a gotcha question
because they'll say oh if you're an
abusive marriage but like I know the ins
and outs of this because I interview the
men that are falsely accused and this is
so common and it's so common so and the
one thing that guys should know is if a
girl says she says she was abused and
she didn't file a police report like
because in family court you don't need
evidence to accuse someone of abuse you
need no evidence and and and and
Criminal Court you do so it's more like
it's more likely true if it's in
criminal court if it's real abuse yeah I
mean you should leave but my issue is
like a lot of times it's not actually
real abuse what they're talking about
and they don't talk about the other side
where a lot of times the girls start it
thank you I don't know as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible